well attorney Michael avenatti and one
of his clients could face a criminal
investigation stemming from the Brett
Kavanaugh Supreme Court confirmation his
client Julie sweat NIC is one of several
women who accused Kavanaugh of sexual
misconduct Senate Judiciary Committee
Chairman Chuck Grassley claims avenatti
and sweat Nick made false allegations
Paula Reid is at the Justice Department
with the latest Paula good morning good
morning senator Grassley is asking the
Justice Department to look into whether
avenatti and sweat Nick intentionally
lied to the committee in an effort to
interfere with its investigation into
Kavanaugh but avenatti says he welcomes
a probe as an opportunity to vindicate
his client thank you senator Grassley
thank you it is Christmas in October
michael avenatti says senator Grassley
opened a Pandora's box by asking the
Justice Department to investigate
whether he and his client Julie sweat
Nick violated federal law during Justice
Cavanaugh's confirmation we're gonna put
judge Kavanaugh on trial and we're going
to test his credibility against that of
me and my client we welcome that fight
sweat Nick alleged Kavanaugh and his
friends drugged female students at house
parties so they could gang rape them
Kavanaugh vigorously denied the
allegations the sweat Nick thing is a
joke that is a farce in his 12 page
letter senator Grassley says there was
simply no credible evidence that Miss
sweat Nick ever even met or socialized
with judge Kavanaugh
IVA Nadia's considering a presidential
run in 2020 I'm getting more serious by
the week because I'm travelling around
the country and people are encouraging
me to do it but comments he made this
week to Time magazine will likely rile
some of his supporters avenatti said the
party's nominee in 2020 better be a
white male because quote when you have a
white male making the arguments they
carry more weight I don't think there's
anything wrong with calling out people
that look like me for not doing enough
to defend women and minorities and
people of color and I'm going to
continue to do that the Justice
Department has not said whether or not
it will pursue this referral if it does
avenatti will likely try to paint it as
a politically motivated investigation
but many Republicans believe it is
Cavanaugh who is the true victim here
and would like to see this pursued Norah
that'll be interesting Paula thank you